scream is available in theaters
nationwide tomorrow on friday january
14th and this is uh the second time i
introduce you now for a new audience
jack wade good to see you here sir hello
new audience
so we just saw a clip of this film what
can you tell fans of this remarkably
successful
series of films man i can't say much but
what i can say is
i i mean you know scream is back and
scream i feel like has always been a
movie
for horror buffs i feel like it makes
horror buffs out of
out of out of people i remember uh being
like four years old uh and it was like
my first halloween trick-or-treating and
i went out and screamed the original had
just come out and all of a sudden i saw
around me in that neighborhood like
every other kid was wearing a ghost face
costume and it traumatized me i was like
no thank you
nope i don't want to i don't want to see
more of this um there was one kid that
had like a translucent
ghost face mask that you could like pump
fake blood down so it looked like it was
right but it's still in my nightmares
it's it's it's terrible but uh uh if you
had told my four-year-old self that i
would one day be in a scream movie he
would he would run away crying um but
i'm glad that uh i'm glad that i am
eventually i
you know started watching more horror
movies and finally faced my fear got to
the original scream and it made a horror
fan out of me right you know it
it's a kind of a gateway drug to horror
in a way that's how i like to describe
it because it it's always making you
know it's a great movie but it's also
making references to other horror movies
so you want to go out and watch those
and and i did
uh
so i think for the for the scream fans i
can say this is a love letter to you um
you're really going to get a kick out of
it um and scream still has your back
like i i think it's scary i think it's
funny it still has that meta
commentary to it and um i mean i'm very
biased but i i love it well i mean so
clearly you know you're a man of your
own right we'll talk about the boys uh
in a second but did you did you fan boy
any of your cast members yeah when you
first got to see cause there's some
some uh original cast in this obviously
nev campbell is coming here on tuesday
oh cool yes indeed we're excited about
that about cox david arquette just to
name you know a few did you did you
fanboy
i call them the og-3 and uh yes i
fanboyed uh over all of them they're
they're all incredible uh
david arquette i think i had just
watched have you seen his documentary
yes it's kind of all
nutty it's so good i loved it so much i
just watched it and i i i met him and i
was like i i don't know how to
compliment somebody on a documentary
about themselves i was like you were so
good in your documentary you're like
you're not acting i don't know why i'm
like you existed in it and i enjoyed it
playing yourself even though you were
doing just nothing but being yourself
exactly because it's about yourself you
were yourself very well right you know
uh but he was he was the best he taught
us all uh
how to paint
uh yeah he is a certified bob ross
painting instructor
yeah yeah of course he is
like he's the guy again for the with the
afro who talks about the beautiful
clouds and stuff like does he do that
commentary as he's painting as well yeah
it's like there's a he i guess took a
course in florida or something and got
certified and
he's actually allowed to teach the bob
ross painting technique and what yeah
this is a real i love this is why i love
david this is real wow this is amazing
amazing that wasn't in the documentary
uh no but there should be a whole
separate documentary about david all
about painting i think okay um but uh
yeah he had us all down in this common
room all the new cast members and
we all just uh he just led a class like
he would look over and you know check
everybody's work i still have my
painting that i made in my place what
did you paint some happy little trees
uh you know a lake in a mountainscape
and it was uh you know it was very very
relaxing it was great
happy little happy little treat again
like that's what i'm saying like if you
become certified it's got to be more
than just teaching someone how to paint
you have to have that
that voice yeah it's got to be soothing
like you can't be manic right you've
gotta you've got so does is that part of
it he's very he's a very calm person
like you know in the movies he's very
you know because we all have to be
scared all the time we all have to be a
little bit more you know manic but you
know he's very calm david to me is a
very calming presence and that you know
that whole
session was just was just amazing
wow yeah that is something that makes me
better for having known it to be very
honest with you i'd like to share it
with the world
on the rich eisen show and that's that's
an original that you're thinking
that's an original um and so then uh
what was it like to actually do this
film like actually perform it it was
amazing i mean i i've done like one
horror movie before uh called tragedy
girls and and that kind of had a a lot
it was inspired by scream uh but this i
don't know just to be within the actual
franchise right something so iconic was
you know when i got cast i i couldn't
really believe it i i i still can't kind
of can't believe it um
but to work alongside legends like that
and then to work with this this new
group of
castmates was amazing because we shot it
during
i was about to say the height of the
pandemic but just
the pandemic which we're still in right
um but we shot it there and it was um in
north carolina north carolina wilmington
north carolina uh shout out to
wilmington there we go i love you um
but you know i just gotten from being
very isolated and then to get this job
and to get to interact with people again
and
and have them be really cool like you
know it's a cliche but it felt like
summer camp where we all just kind of
became one
big family and there was a lot of love
there and it's also a movie about murder
so it's it was a very it was an odd
balance but it was one of the best
experiences i've ever had shooting
anything we call it a dichotomy no doubt
about that we call it a dichotomy for
sure jackquaid92 on twitter
[Music]
didn't have football uh here growing up
right um now i do i need to go i've been
to one rams game uh and i had a really
good time but uh yeah i was i was a
sports fan
in like the shack kobe era
uh it was i mean that was that was the
time that was the best time it was so
fun shaq kobier so you were you're just
a little kid going to games watching
shaq and kobe win championships yeah i
think the best part of it though was uh
occasionally
like jack nicholson was there yes and uh
i would go with my dad and my dad sort
of knew him and every time i would see
him jack nicholson would look at me and
know my name was jack and i think
assumed that i was named after him
he would go like jack eh i see what you
did there like there was that kind of
thing
and we never told him anything to the
contrary uh of course not why would you
i know i mean i'll let him believe that
it was just uh that was my favorite
thing so it's like shaq kobe nicholson
that was the that was the way to go
that's it and you're clearly named after
jack nicholson i would never just abuse
him of any single notion whatsoever sure
let's make that cannon i'm named after
jack so no dodgers you didn't go to
anything
yeah i know i went to dodgers games too
i think that
that was more like occasional i feel
like lakers i was really i was really
into i went to some angels games as well
uh the year they won the the world
series which was a thousand i believe it
was 2000 right around there yeah okay
yeah it was great 2002 2002. yeah
that was my last year on espn i tried
you know that's been so long ago i know
uh the boys let's talk about this let's
talk about it here oh cool all right you
just did you just wake up i'm very in i
mean what i'm doing i'm just thinking
i'm listening i'm doing it but i'm very
into the boys great show oh thank you
it's phenomenal thanks so much yeah we
it's uh it's so messed up right yeah
that's the thing is like you try to
explain it to me because i try to tell
people hey you should watch the boys
it's great you'll love it yeah what's it
about okay so how do i describe this i
had this same problem right yeah it
basically
think about superheroes and after the
worst possible people ever totally i had
the same problem when the show had not
been out yet i
tried to kind of elevate or pitch it to
my friends and there's just a lot there
once you see it you understand right
right i was like they're superheroes and
they're real in this world but they're
bad i'm not a superhero like i was like
they were like what and then i just kind
of described that that first scene that
you really see me in where my girlfriend
meets uh
her end spoilers it's in the first
episode but i think when people watch
that scene they were like oh i get it
yeah what if
you know the uh there's collateral
damage that happens if superheroes
actually actually existed in our world
and uh i love it it's also such a great
satire and i love being in something so
satirical that can comment on real world
events like that yeah june 3rd 2022
we have a dream yeah you got it emmy
nominated series the boys and so
do you do people think when they run
into you that you're
somebody that's letting them down like
literally meeting you in person that
sort of thing like like uh are they
disappointed to meet me sometimes no no
no no letting that that you are somebody
who is uh not a superhero oh god that
sort of thing yeah i mean they're just
they've just been nice they've been like
huey and i'm like yes
and that's the interaction i guess but
um but uh no i don't know yeah there is
that kind of odd thing where you're like
i'm on a superhero show and they're like
do you have powers and i'm like no
i don't
i'm a guy that works in an electronics
store but uh you know i i react to
things uh i guess
but i have so much fun working on that
show and the cast is amazing they're
also we've become this family at this
point i'm covered in blood most of the
time okay uh
fake blood
i should i should i should clarify
we need to make sure yeah we should we
should tell people um but it's just a
blast and uh we just
wrapped our third season and i can't say
much about it but it's you can't say
anything about what you're doing
everything is shrouded in
mystery
in your i just saw you had a little
hitch in your giddy up you're like you
didn't want to give away a spoiler of
the first episode of something that's
about to have a third season that you've
already shot like i want to apologize to
america for the hitch in my giddyup
i want you to just just be
be free jeff okay
i mean like but you can't give away i
mean scream is about to hit yeah that i
i can't give away that'll just ruin the
experience i don't remember the last
movie again where where a film sends out
to all of their fans when you see it
shut up
but just give us a good word of mouth of
saying you should see it but don't say
anything about what it is
i do too
it's great i do too because you don't
want to know before you go it's kind of
like recording a live sporting event
though like you got to keep it quiet you
know like if somebody's on sports
blackout
but you can't but here's the difference
is you when somebody's recorded
something on sports blackout you can't
even say wait till you see it uh because
that blows it up it's just like oh so
it's not a blast why is something crazy
right
i really like the one it's like right
you know what i mean i can say that all
the time wait till you see this season
oh my god this season that's the
difference yeah that actually helps
on that front yeah okay so are there
more screams in the shoot here can you
even say that i can't i don't i don't
know like here's the here's the other
thing
your future uh maybe okay there you go
it's amazing
no hitch in my giddyup when it comes to
priuses they're very good i i had one
for a while since 2013. it was i
although i did leave i went to like a
party or something it was like a
barbecue and i remember i brought um a
bunch of like burgers yeah and i bought
i brought a lot of like
turkey burgers and then i some of them
weren't cooked after the party i i put
them back in my car and then for some
reason i just did not take them out of
the car and then i left town for two
weeks
and so that prius smelled like raw
uncooked turkey burgers for um months so
that's the first horror movie ever
exactly
my my prius
smelled like there was a corpse in it
and that's why priuses are scary there
you go this is what i'm saying but if
you're the guy who's driving on the
prius you're more than likely than not
than the guy that i pass uh in the left
lane and have to see the face of you
know because i have to see who's driving
so damn slow like i'd literally have to
give that look yeah if you were in that
scene they should have added you into
that scene and there's the guy going
like hey come on move it i know the
producer so i'm more than happy to be in
the next one and shout out to william
sharrick and now if you know uh and
william i should speak to william he
would know uh i'm you know campaigning
to be the next host of the oscars i've
done oh my god
you know actually i saw that in the
green room yes i'm rooting for you man
well you know oh so you saw in the green
room i saw you campaigning oh okay
oh you know sure
people shouted at me uh from their cars
well that's another word of mouth how
about that i i will give great word of
mouth to scream okay and uh and you you
know tell everyone in your circle you
would be a great host of the oscars yeah
rich eisen okay cool when when this clip
comes out and they see that we've had we
have an arrangement yes um do you think
that would complicate things at all no
because i have no shame oh okay great
okay there you go that's whole thing let
me check i am shameless let me check if
i do i have zero shame about this at all
yeah so okay whatever yeah let's do it
there is an eye and rich and eisen you
understand that's the way i'm a host i'm
a television host i should have no shame
at all you host you host things that's
what i do professionally yeah i host and
i promote and i love the movies i love
the movies here we go you know so
well i'm rooting for you man i will
shout
[Music]
right i called a callback and i called
it that's it it's a call back mania
that's what i was trying i didn't mean
to correct you i was just no i don't
know it's okay that's all right you just
undercut my entire
opinion of myself shows a really
impeccable host
actually has a prius it's parked outside
he wants you to autograph it he's too
afraid
you have a prius yeah
what i'm autographing are you the only
guy who owns a prius and a range rover
probably pretty pretty much honestly
close like it's initially does that kind
of even out to like a honda civic
the only thing that's more outside those
margins is a smart car and a mybach you
know what i mean
oh oh the big that's like the big
expensive mercedes yeah is that like
that's the ones where the doors open up
you know you have a driver that's out
like a fold or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's a butler in the trunk
that's right
yeah
there's like there's like blinds right
yeah curtains blinds closed down yeah
okay so it's like a little house
pretty it's like a g5 on the ground
though i agree it says blinds i mean i
added those in i wanted to know
my buck
one day and this is gonna be my dream
i'm going to leave turkey burgers into
my box
[Laughter]
let's do it
[Applause]
by the way that's the title song of jack
quaid's new album turkey's in my mind
turkey
gobble gobble
[Music]
the success that scream is going to be
in theaters nationwide tomorrow friday
january 14th season three of the boys
make a note of it right now i know
exactly what i'll be doing on june 3rd
2022. i fell asleep watching the boys
last night oh hell yeah he went to bed
watching no you don't you can't say that
no
i like that that was a compliment though
at all
i was watching i went on a little binge
i got up to like episode five and i it
was like two one in the morning okay if
you if you got to episode five before
you fell asleep that's a really good
sign thank you i appreciate that [ __ ]
compliment yes
his heart was in the right place you
watched it until you fell asleep exactly
phrasing wasn't the best yeah the number
of times
that i heard i'm sorry
uh when i was on sportscenter back in
the day at the 2 a.m eastern show that's
late no but 11 o'clock out here from
people out here saying that they fell
asleep watching me on television it's
just it
it just it hurts i think you took i
think you take things the wrong way i
think i think jack knew it was a
compliment i'll say i'll say this though
like i think it's a compliment because
every night i fall asleep watching like
seasons uh i want to see like three
through nine of the simpsons which i
consider like the best tv ever so that
that's a compliment you know people
like with the office or whatever you
know that's like a thing that people
that
suits people okay so it's not a it's not
an insult if he says i fell asleep
watching your work on something else but
if you fell asleep during that answer
that's an insult yes
are you awake
[Laughter]
everybody ch
on twitter
on instagram hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here